on va passer à l'invité du soir euh on
va revenir sur Sébastien cohé pour
rappel l'animateur il visait par trois
plaintes pour agression sexuelle et viol
il a fait une interview sur BFM TV on va
revenir là-dessus et on va revenir sur
c'est la première fois que Sébastien C
s'exprimer sur BFM TV et sa femme
Nathalie d'tois la femme de coé sera
avec nous dans un instant pour une
interview exclusive également on va
revenir d'abord sur son interview d'hier
à Koé sur BFM il était sur BFM TV
dimanche 18h avec cel i voilà que
Benjamin duamel le le le le le petit
génie euh des stagiaires regardez petit
génie à l'intérieur je suis en morceau
je suis dévasté je subis ces attaques et
ces accusations pour lesquelles je suis
évidemment complètement innocent je suis
accusé de choses que je n'ai pas fait
viol ce n'est pas rien je suis accusé de
viol ou agression sexuelle ça n'est pas
rien et vous êtes présumé innocent oui
alors je suis présumé innocent il y a
une petite différence entre le procès
médiatique qui va très très vite et et
la justice à laquelle nous avons donné
beaucoup de choses moi je moi je alors
moi je suis sur le plateau en
direct et je découvre l'interview parce
que en fait je en fait je l'ai pas vu
hier je ne regarde jamais ce jeune homme
qui est insupportable pour moi voilà et
il le sait et il a dit tiens et il a dit
comme il est venu avec un garçon que je
connaissais hier à l'interview il a dit
oui tu pourras dire à Cyril il y en a
que je n'ai jamais été son stagiaire oui
oui son père m'a demandé mais je ne l'ai
jamais pris je crois il faudrait que je
revois dans mes fiches mais je crois que
j'ai bien fait de ne pas le prendre
voilà son père qui était très
sympathique sa mère aussi mais c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment un fils à papa
et à maman euh donc on va revenir sur
l'interview Sébastien cé a tenu à
rappeler qu'il avait été le premier à
porter plainte dans cette affaire
regardez je suis je suis le premier
plaignant dans cette histoire je suis le
premier à avoir porté plainte j'ai subi
pendant un mois des horreurs des
montages des faux sur Twitter que mes
enfants ont vu que tout le monde a vu je
suis allé déposer plainte pour
harcèlement
2 jours plus tard arrive une plainte
avec quelque chose qui n'avait jamais
été dit jusque- là qui était le mot viol
il ne se passe rien dans 51 ans de ma
vie je dépose une plainte pour
harcèlement 2 jours après arrive une
plainte pour un motif qui n'avait jamais
existé
oui ah oui alors c'est toute la question
c'est vrai qu'il a été le premier à
porter plainte he pour cyberhcèlement ça
c'est factuellement vrai après est-ce
qu'il a porté plainte parce qu'il savait
que les plaintes pour viol allaient
arriver lui il dit qu'il savait qu'il y
avait un autour de lui voilà il voyait
le truc arriver alors il a également
évoqué sa plainte pour extorsion de fond
indiquant avoir des preuves irréfutables
regardez monsur duamel tout est faux
tout est mensongé j'ai entre les mains
et nous avons avec mes avocats entre les
mains des documents qui ont permis de
déposer plainte pour montrer qu'il y
avait tentative d'extorsion de fond en
bande organisée ces documents ont été
remis à la police et l'enquête est en
cours et l'enquête est en cours je crève
d'envie j'en chial le soir si c'est ça
que vous voulez savoir de ne pas pouvoir
vous montrer ni à vous ni à d'autres les
preuves irréfutables qu'on a donné à la
police mon oui lui il prétend il dit
qu'il a les documents qui vont attester
devant les enquêteurs et devant la
justice d'un complot qu'il dénonce qui
serait ourd depuis plusieurs mois à un
moment il a même dit plusieurs années
potentiellement mais il ne veut pas
encore nommer les comploteurs présumés
parce qu'il réserve ça à la justice oui
tout a été remis à la justice c'est pour
ça qu'il préserve pour le moment alors
il est également revenu sur sa mise en
retrait des des centaines d'énergies
regardez pour faire rire les gens il
faut un minimum être bien je pense que
j'aurais été incapable de faire 4 heures
de direct tous les jours pour 2 millions
de gens ça fait 20 ans que je travaille
avec énergie 13 ans que l'ont fait cette
émission on a fabriqué des succès
incroyable j'aime cette marque j'aime la
relation qu'on a installé ensemble on a
une confiance on se connaît depuis 20
ans c'est pas rien dans les
médias j'espère aujourd'hui reprendre le
micro parce que le micro le micro c'est
ma vie quand on quand on le décidera et
quand Energie le décidera je je n'ai
qu'une hâte vous savez moi je je ne sais
faire que du divertissement depuis que
je suis gamin
oui l'envie de revenir elle est là on le
sent ça brûle voilà tout à fait alors
après est-ce qu'éergie va devoir
attendre ou va vouloir attendre la fin
de toute la procédure ce qui serait très
long est-ce que vous pensez pas
qu'Energie do do le remettre à l'antenne
avant oou ils doivent attendre la
procédure parce que non regardez dans
les autres éd normalement les mecs
restent à l'antenne oui ça va durer des
années oui donc énergie il faut qu'il le
remett à l'antenne je pense que là il
commence à réfléchir ah oui et je pense
oui et je pense que Sébastien cé leur
dit tendez-moi à la paire je suis prêt à
reprendre parce que comme il le dit un
humoriste il pouvait pas faire rire là
ils se sonent galvanisé par ces plaintes
il y a trois plaintes d'un côté trois
plaintes de l'autre et je pense qu'il a
envie de reprendre c'est possible Cyril
qu'à la rentrée il y a des discussions
vraiment avancé pour qu'il puisse
reprendre voilà en tout cas c'était d'
commment un cœur de deux des deux
énergie et lui non mais c'est jamais
d'un commun accord siil dit tu crois
tout ce qu'on
dit commord tuas pleurer
ici sur les déclarations de la chanteuse
quiacuse d'agression sexuelle s
eximégalementil vous plaît la chanteuse
expliqueen 2008 invité de votre émission
surnergie je la cite il me tend laajou
pour un bisou je me sens obligé de
m'exécuter pu au dernier moment il se
retourne et m'embrasse sur la
bouche rien ne va dans ce que dit elle
parle la seule fois où elle est invité
c'est dans la méthode coé donc
c'estàdire qu'elle ment elle n'est Jama
c'est pas mentir je vous invite à
regarder la séquence elle est disponible
partout sur internet c'est une séquence
sous le Guy c'est une séquence de 31
décembre méthode C diffusée c'est le
baiser le plus consenti de la Terre et
qui est demandé et qui est fait le plus
naturellement du monde les émissions
étaient enregistrées le lundi elles
étaient diffusées le jeudi elle avait
toute la possibilité d'enlever une
séquence qu'elle aurait trouvé gênante
voilà oui alors oui c'est compliqué sur
cette question Cyril sur le baiser là
parce qu' la question du consentement
qui se pose il dit elle aurait eu 4
jours pour se retourner est-ce que par
exemple si on est en état de sidération
on est capable de se retourner voilà là
c'est une question vraiment comp on voir
la séquence vous vu Mo j'ai vu les
images sur
Twitter Twitter lui sur Twitter il a un
regardez attention qu'est-ce que comment
on fait bisou en début d'année quand il
y a du gu on fait bisous sur la bouche
quand il y a du gu on se place sous le
gu et on fait bisous il y a pas de gu le
gu ah ben ça va oh tu veux pas lui
mettre la branche sur la gueule aussi
tant que tu y es al accuseele hein bon B
c'est la tradition
ouais c'est pas trop c moi moi je suis
super gêné parce qu'en fait j'ai lu
l'article de lib et j'ai je crois tout
ce qui est écrit dans la l'article et
j'ai écouté Sébastien cé et j'ai cru
tout ce qu'il m'a dit c'est ça j'ai
trouvé j'ai trouvé que c'était en fait
je trouvéis qu'il y avait un avant et un
après moi j'avais jamais vu quelqu'un
qui arrivait comme ça à la télévision
pendant 30 minutes et qui s'exprimait
frontalement franchement j'ai j'ai
trouvé que c'était une sorte de machine
de guerre médiatiqueère et je l'ai
trouvé je en fait je l'ai cru donc je ne
sais pas et quand à cette image ouais
2008 ça se passe en
2008 elle elle considère que c'est une
agression sexuelle je respecte
évidemment sa sa sensation mais moi
effectivement aujourd'hui avec mes
lunettes de 2023 même de 2023 pour moi
ça n'est pas une agression sexuelle mais
avec moi Géraldine maillet avec ma
sensibilité donc effectivement c'est
très compliqué de juger en 2023 une
image qui s'est passée en 2008 parce que
la télévision n'était pas la même et
ilexlique très bien Koé alors euh vous
l'avez dit hier coé était sur BFM il
n'était pas face un journaliste mais il
s'est retrouvé face à la 10e chambre du
tribunal judiciaire de Paris regardez
le les postes clés de mon entreprise
sont des femmes mais
pardon prendre les choses dans
l'ordre et pour qu'on reste sur les
faits j'aimerais qu'on commence avec les
faits ce sont des accusations très
graves je rappelle évidemment que vous
êtes présumé innocent est-ce que vous
reconnaissez le récit qui est fait par
Julie Olivier ou est-ce que vous
contestez les fait monsieur duamel tout
est faux et tout est mensonge un mot
encore sur cette tentative d'extortion
de FO en band organisé de quand
date-t-elle comme si dans sa tête il
était venu juste pour ça comme si
j'étais un être sans sans aucune
importance je je termine Sébastien si
vous le voulez bien donc croyez-vous
vraiment que c'est l'ambiance ce qui est
décrite c'est en tout cas ces
témoignages là qui sont décrits qui
montrre une forme d'Abu de pouvoir je
rappelle Sébastien c que vous êtes
présumé innocent et que évidemment la
justice fera la loi c'est moi